buonasera a tutti io sono stefani e sono
ben voi direte che forse sta un po
esagerando voce sottile un pò tonda non
sto esagerando io sono besa io sono qui
e lo rimarrò per sempre per sempre io
dipendo dal cibo esattamente come si può
dipendere
dall'alcool dalle droghe o dal gioco io
dipendo dal cibo
ho vissuto un'adolescenza a 145 kg euro
questa è stata un adolescenza difficile
molto pesante e ingombrante oserei dire
io dovevo essere sempre la più simpatica
più gentile la più disponibile per tutti
era importantissimo non potevo
permettermi di essere tematica in alcun
modo non me le permettevano la mia
felicità perché ne avrebbero non mi
accettavano devo essere splendida dentro
perché fuori ero davvero brutta un po
migliorata provero proprio brutta
quando era a scuola
chiaramente non so c'era l'ora di vedere
dove però faccio un qualche esempio
quando era di far merenda facevamo tutti
merenda qualcuno mi passava di fianco mi
diceva tu mangi
mi raccomando mangia stavo facendo
esattamente tutto quello che facevano
gli altri mangiava ma non mi era
concesso
è stato difficile anche nel momento
della dell'ora di ginnastica che era uno
dei momenti più terribili per me l'ora
di ginnastica e tutta dinamici tutti
felici tutti sportivi e non so se
ricordate si facevano
due squadre per la pallavolo
pallacanestro qualsiasi sforzo si
tendeva a fare due squadre da prof
prendeva i due soggetti quelli più
sportivi e faceva a fare le squadre io
ero sempre l'ultima non mi sceglie
l'hanno mai era impossibile che mi
scegliessero e sceglievano soltanto
quando per ultimo mancava una persona e
non vi dico le facce della gente che poi
aveva dei miei compagni di squadra alla
peggiore il maniero con la prof
la prof di ginnastica che avevano
eccezionali fianco e quindi mi faceva
passare sotto la cavallina ma non ci
passavo saltare la cavallina mano la
saltavo quindi girava intorno
sempre intorno a questa cavallina che
ancora io odio
c'era il momento della gita la gita era
sempre per l'ascolano cosa bellissimo
momento
la cosa più bella della gita erano i tre
giorni nei quali si andava per musei per
città si andava a vedere di tutto di più
poi c'era la giornata dello shopping
quella libera nella quale tutti andavamo
a fare shopping
bene le mie amiche andavano sempre per
negozi
acquistavano intimi abbigliamento di
tutto di più salivano sul pole ma è
chiaramente con tutte le loro borsine io
ho dovuto trovare un escamotage non
c'erano negozi che avessero le taglie
per me non usava non c'era ancora la
moda quella che si chiama accordi e
quindi un bell éscamotage perché questa
foto delle scarpe perché io ho
cominciato ad acquistare scarpe perché
il 40 il 40 e mi andava bene per cui
anche io andavo in pullman con la mia
borsina con le scarpe sempre tacco 12 in
trent'anni a questa parte io ho
collezionato 280 poco più paia di scarpe
tacco 12 perché quelle perché erano un
po la mia copertina di linus quando me
li mettevo un po perché slanciano e
quindi mi sembrava di diluire il peso e
un po perché mi dicevano più belle gambe
e io non mi sentivo più bella con quelle
scarpe tanto più bella però era una
sofferenza perché camminarci non è vero
che sono comode una bugia
e allora anche adesso io vado sempre in
giro con le scarpe coi tacchi sempre è
una sorta e tra la scarpa una schiavitù
è una copertina di linus è molto
difficile perché magari quelli cui in
centro che ci sono tutti i sanpietrini
mi piacerebbe guardarmi intorno
in realtà per non fare figuracce
semplicemente guardo per terra per non
infila ritratti nei giochini e avrei
voglia di togliermi le scarpe a buttarle
via centre mib l uguale ma non ce la
faccio o quando ce la farò bene o male e
vorrà dire che comincia a metabolizzare
e sono grande abbastanza per poterlo
fare io sono sempre stata quel pacco
bruttissimo che nessuno mai scelto
immaginate un regalo incarnato brutto
brutto brutto tenza fiocchi senza scotch
senza niente proprio alla bene meglio e
consegnato
se non lo consegnati lasciato in una
montagna di pochi nessuno lo sceglie è
impossibile
e sempre così e stata una vita è un
adolescenza così e poi per assurdo vi
racconto una cosa buffa allora quando
non c'erano ancora tutta questa
tecnologia
i dati anagrafici si dovevano vera voce
allora nome stefania cognome camurri
nata il 21 4 70 e spero 52 anni facendo
il calcolo e questo faceva un primo
via
chiletti
io abitavo in via chiletti i miei
genitori avevano deciso così di una casa
in via che letti non vi dico i volti
delle persone alle quali una ragazza di
145 kg diceva che abitava in via ciletti
erano di tutto di più ho visto gente che
rideva la gente che sogghignava gente
imbarazzata ho visto di tutto e a
proposito della mia famiglia che abitava
in via chiletti
questa è penso l'unica foto che ho della
mia famiglia a casa a mangiare tutti
insieme perché sapete cosa facevano loro
erano dei ristoratori o li
abbiamo detto quasi tutto il ristoratore
non è un mestiere
il ristoratore è uno stile di vita non
c'è niente non ci sono domeniche non ci
sono sabati non ci sono sera non ci sono
cinema non c'è niente non ci sono i
genitori che vengono alle riunioni con
gli insegnanti certo che vengono ma
nelle ore rubate tra un'ora buca e
l'altra
non c'è proprio niente di una vita
normale però c'è tanto di una cosa c'è
tutto il cibo del mondo e non era quello
di cui avevo bisogno assolutamente un
forse sì non lo so io odiavo quel
mestiere
odiavo il mio corpo odiavo quella vita
ma era quella che permetteva i miei
genitori di farmi studiare perché io non
un sogno ho studiato lingue fatto la
scuola per interpreti e volevo diventare
hostess di volo che come una fisicità
del genere ovviamente a meno che le
compagnie aeree non avessero deciso di
ampliare i corridoi degli aerei mi
sarebbe potuto stato possibile
insiste volevo farcela ma davvero quando
ho metabolizzato sapevo di non poterlo
fare
semplicemente ho avuto un'idea
ho detto faccio la hostess di terra è
più semplice no sono dietro un desk che
torna a scrivere in quegli aeroporti
dove io spesso andavo a vedere da carpi
partivo e andavo a vedere nel rapporto
di verona che non è tanto distante
guardavo partire questi mi davano un
senso di libertà e di leggerezza avevo
volevo scappare andare via da cosa non
lo so ma io volevo scappare non mi
piaceva niente sapevo che ero forte
nelle lingue perché scogliera davvero
brava ma non perché fossi più
intelligente degli altri assolutamente
ma era un modo studiare per dire le
amiche che non potevo uscire perché
dovevo studiare
e così è stato faccio una domanda
per fare la hostess di terra
quindi vado a bologna
vado a fare questa domanda e la cena
dice ovviamente anche lì cartacea
eccetera eccetera tutte le scartoffie
del caso dice
capirà serve la foto a figura intera
quello è stato il new sliding doors in
quel momento io ho capito che non potevo
perseverare non dovevo non era possibile
non potevo neanche fare la vostra si
terra il mestiere dei miei genitori era
diventato tutto in un momento una
ricchezza perché avevo deciso di andare
a lavorare con loro di smettere di studi
a me mancava un anno per finire alla
scuola per interpreti non l'ho finita
perché ho deciso di fare un intervento
chirurgico allora sperimentale allo
stomaco pionieristico io sapevo per le
carte che hanno firmato che potevo anche
di partire come si dice era il 16
gennaio del 1994 e 24 anni
[Applauso]
belle le scarpe
la sera prima ho mangiato di tutto di
tutto di più tutto quello che si poteva
mangiare perché sapevo che dopo non
avrei avrei mangiato molto meno e così è
stato fino a mezzanotte perché lo
ammettono che era l'ora fatidica degli
interventi che puntano a mezzanotte ho
smesso di mangiare ho vomitato ho detto
va bene vomito non sapevo che quella
sarebbe stata una lunga serie di
gomitate
in un anno ho perso la metà del mio peso
questa è la mia cicatrice del quale non
vada assolutamente sera ma la tengo ben
cara perché è stato un intervento
doloroso come tutti gli interventi ma
insomma particolare me la ricordo me la
guardo ma la tengo lì e mi piace che la
vediate
dunque mangiato tutto comitato in un
anno perso la metà del mio peso
nel frattempo lavoravo quei miei
genitori
ma capivo che qualcosa non andava mi
interessava il giusto perché ero
dimagrita tanto ero felice avevo
raggiunto
quella vita che avrei diciamo quel peso
che avrei voluto raggiungere da una vita
ma avevo 26 anni 25 26 anni
lavoro coi miei genitori
dimagrisco appunto il peso giusto ma mi
rendo conto davvero che qualcosa non va
perché io da allora è ormai sono quasi
30 anni non posso più mangiare niente di
solido nulla io non mangio né carne né
pesce
né pasta nei pali niente che sia solido
il mio stomaco contiene 33 c c come una
lattina a un foro da lì non passa nulla
che sia solita meno che e non mangi
liquidi o cose cremose e
la cosa buffa però è che io mangerei
tutto anche voi qui così crudi così come
siete
tutto mangerei perché sono ben sa qui e
lo rimarrà per sempre come vi dicevo
sapete che mestiere faccio
io faccio
alla fine faccia la chef questo è il mio
libro dove racconto la mia storia
ma per fare questo mestiere e io come se
fossi colui che si deve a disintossicare
dall'alcol fossi in un bar a spillare
birre sono come un ludopatico che si
deve disintossicare dal gioco è
semplicemente deve ruotare le
macchinette dei barga le monetine
io uguale cucina cui livelli cioè io
cucino mangerei so che non posso perché
non è chiuso la mia testa non è guarita
guarito il mio stomaco non posso mi ha
impedito qualsiasi cosa assaggio io vado
in bagno corre vomito con un ristorante
non è magnifico che la cuoca corre fuori
vomiti
quindi ho dovuto cercare
di creare qualcosa di diverso
ho studiato tutte le materie prime
immaginabili possibili
tutto quello che ti dalla natura le
forme le consistenze i colori e cerco di
fare i piatti che siano qualcosa di
diverso che se li guardo non mi viene
voglia di mangiarli perché lì rovino
a un po più arte o la mia arte o quello
che io definisco arte senza presunzione
nel senso che per me è diventato
qualcos'altro
sapete come si chiama il mio ristorante
si chiama m'ama non m'ama tutto
attaccato perché io non so se il cibo mi
ama e se io amo il cibo non so nemmeno
se l'odio se lui mi odia quindi per me
quello è il nome più azzeccato
io fatico tanto a fare quel lavoro
fatico tanto nel senso che è un mestiere
di sacrifici ma quando c'è un cliente
che invece di dirmi ho mangiato bene sai
mi dice io ho fatto un'esperienza so che
quelle cose lì io le ho trasformate e
non ha cibo
potrebbe sembrare una sciocchezza ma per
me è così e mi aiuta e poi un giorno sul
mio caldi mino perché nella vita le cose
non capitano mai per caso
e di questo ne sono convinto un po come
via chiletti mi deve portare a qualcosa
incontro la mia splendida val e
valentina bezzi dottoressa valentina
bezzi sessuologa psicologa a una tesi in
dismorfofobia che è la percezione
sbagliata del proprio corpo
ci incontriamo decidiamo di creare un
blog bellissimo che ci diverse da morire
dove non parliamo di sesso e di cibo non
abbiamo mai avuto nessuna difficoltà mai
a trovare un argomento correlato tra
sesso e cibo perché se ci pensate il
sesso e cibo sono le uniche due cose che
hanno in comune tutti i cinque sensi
ci divertiamo e legittimi amo le donne a
parlare di sesso
facciamo divertire che di anche un po
terapeutico parliamo di cibo e ci
divertiamo da matti e anche lì il cibo
diventa qualcosa di diverso
io faccio il cibo
a questa è la mia famiglia i miei figli
fabio che un ristorante io faccio il
cibo quello che
avrei voluto
riuscirà a fare su di me
bello fuori è bello dentro io provo
essere bella dentro mi viene benino
fuori c'è un però va bene così
allora vi dico una cosa
quando mi chiedono ma tu hai vinto o hai
perso
io dico che non ho vinto perché sarei
belen
io non ho perso perché sarei 300 kg io
ho semplicemente capito
e a volte può bastare
allora questo è un posacenere lo
consegno al tavolo spesso al ristorante
la gente ha una faccia schifata di fatto
un posacenere
immondizia lo porti a tavole richiede di
fidarsi di me è lì da un cucchiaino
anno faccio un po storte insisto
affondano il cucchiaino
questa è una panna cotta al con le
sigarette di zucchero la cenere è fatta
col carbone vegetale
e si frulla la meringa
il viso quando li porto il portacenere
proteggendole terribile
quando l'assassino è stupendo e allora
io vi chiedo una cosa che per me è
importante se io qui sul palco sto
facendo qualcosa di buono
vi chiedo di fare come quel post racener
e
vi chiedo di impacchettare nel prossimo
regalo che farete qualsiasi esso sia
chiunque in qualsiasi occasione
incartate lo nel modo più brutto
possibile
brutto
senza fiocchi senza nastri con anche la
carta fritti un import deve essere
brutto consegnato le vedete il volto di
queste persone
allucinato come puoi presentare un
regalo così
quando apriranno quel regalo vi faranno
un sorrisone grande perché quello che
conta
è quello che c'è dentro
e basta e allora in quel momento voi
avrete vinto
e io insieme a voi
grazie